the year is 2019 I was a bright-eyed
youth going into my second year of
college and a couple high school friends
I used to play magic with moved within
walking distance of where I lived we
were all in one place again but none of
us had played much magic recently my
friends each had a single EDH deck theyd
built in high school and I didn't even
have that having recently lost the mono
removal pile I played with in high
school in a move so what was the best
way to play Magic under these
circumstances and on a broke college
student budget revamp our old decks and
or build new ones to match them in power
we pondered this question until noticing
a guild die that had come in a DD dice
set my friend Connor had bought this die
spawned an idea what if rather than
building one or two new decks each we
instead built a lowcost deck for each
Guild and rolled randomly to figure out
what deck we'd play within a given game
this would allow us to play a variety of
different decks without straining our
meager budgets thus began the $25 deck
pool the deck building began in an
interesting place though I knew the
shield R deck of my youth had problems I
was still a black player wanting to do
black player things so I opted to build
an orov control deck putting kbal in the
command Zone offered a great way to keep
the deck's life total up while chipping
away at opposing life totals and allowed
the rest of the deck to focus on removal
draw and various life gain related
combos rather than trying to develop
beaters likewise my friend Hans built a
pretty brutal aorus control list with no
andar in the command Zone and the fact
that the pool began with two control
decks is a factor that shouldn't be
overlooked as other decks got flushed
out this influence can be seen of the
pool's five mid-range decks three were
some form of aristocrats and another was
a land focused deck that didn't rely on
keeping non-land permanence in play the
pool also ended up containing a few more
explosive combo oriented decks and these
were likewise well situated to handle
control consisting of a graveyard
Centric artifacts deck a big Mana deck
and a deck with a number of its own
counter spells finally we have what
ended up being the hardest color
combination to build a $25 deck for deir
for my first attempt I opted for an
artifact tokens list with Rona as the
commander a mid-range deck that could
hopefully be flexible enough to survive
in a wide range of scenarios so this was
the first pool we had and we played
about 30 games with it before going back
to make major changes so how did these
decks pan out in a word interestingly I
kept data on all the games and the orov
deck garnered an eye-watering 54% win
rate its potent mixture of Life gain
suppressive elements and explosive
combos proving too much for opposing
decks among the other decks win rates
varied from 30% all the way down to 0%
and as the zero of the group The ni
maette combo deck got switched out for
an artifact oriented combo deck that
uses its Commander joira to draw into
combo pieces in addition to these wide
power differences a lot of the decks
just felt kind of flat and lifeless
generic mid-range decks doing generic
mid-range things for this reason the
celesia mid-range deck and the tati over
Lands Deck ended up getting swapped out
for a cat's aggro deck and a vanar
toolbox deck both Decks that would
hopefully bring a bit more Zing to the
pool than their predecessors had and
finally The deir Rona deck unfortunately
just did not work and looking at the old
deck list I can see why it was an
unfocused mish mash of vaguely artifact
oriented stuff and it mostly ended up
feeling toothless above all else I
actually retuned the deck to be a
proliferate deck about halfway through
this period of 30 games and that was
decidedly not an improvement for it so
it was at this point where I scrapped
the deck and followed an idea from my
friend Connor to rebuild it as a lazav
deck a sort of graveyard based combo
deck that would use its Commander to
swing big with infect through a card
called Vector ASP with that a commander
swap for aorus and some tuning to all
decks we were ready to try out another
round of games after playing another 30
games with the updated pool the changes
seemed to be working out pretty well
there was a more even spread among the
win rates and the new combo decks were
working out just fine lazav was sitting
comfortably mid-pack in terms of win
rate its mixture of controlling and
combo elements able to pull through
winds often enough intriguingly orov won
W literally none of its 11 games within
this period mostly due to players
pressuring it down first in most of its
games however its place of dominance was
taken by a different deck cats
commanding a 42% win rate the cats deck
ended up being a truly ruthless aggro
Deck with the deck's Commander pumped
cats putting on heavy pressure as early
as turn two the deck was also able to
fit in enough draw to grind into the
late game and this one-w punch was too
much for a lot of the slower decks in
the pool with strong performances from
some faster decks the golgari and ratos
Aristocrats decks were deemed a bit too
slow and Bland and ended up getting
swapped out for two more aggressive
Dynamic decks a grismold tokens deck and
a discard Deck with malagor as the
commander additionally in the wake of
cats making a large Splash within the
pool several slower decks were modified
to have additional life gain board wipes
and creatures to block with Within These
10 decks a meaningful metag game had
been developed a metag game where
lacking ways to hold hold off
creature-based aggression was something
that would cause a deck to win fewer
games the next period with these 10
decks is interesting because of just how
long it lasted with no major alterations
to the deck pool though this period
lasted just under 6 months of real world
time there happened to be some societal
factors that hindered other forms of
socialization so we ended up playing 86
games in that time frame this fact
itself indicates that this pool was
actually pretty good both in terms of
deck balance and in terms of how the
decks felt this is also the first time I
had a big enough sample size to consider
the stats halfway reliable and
balance-wise the decks ended up grouping
into three clusters in terms of win rate
the most powerful deck in this period
was the simic toolbox mid-range deck
winning a third of its games and this is
likely because it's just a very
well-rounded deck it was able to keep up
a moderately above average win rate
after the pool's metag game had been
figured out as opposed to the orov and
celesia decks which had each had their
moments of EX ex dominance before
eventually being adapted to by other
decks speaking of those the next cluster
contained five Decks that all had a high
20s win percentage the orov control deck
the celesia cats deck the goari grismold
deck the zorus control deck and the gr
big Mana deck the lowest cluster was in
the High Teens decidedly not a terrible
win rate I feel it should be noted but
not a great one either and this group
contained the boros eggs deck the ratos
discard deck and the two combo decks
despite holding up decently in the
previous round of games both combo decks
put on a pretty lackluster performance
in these 86 games and I chalk this up to
two factors for one their play patterns
got figured out for the lazav deck this
meant that people could know roughly how
quickly the deck would achieve its combo
and also what weak points should be
targeted when in order to disrupt the
deck the other factor is that the pool
had become significantly more aggressive
as the number of aggro decks increased
and as slower decks added more creatures
to Stave off pressure and ultimately the
lazav deck's biggest weakness is that it
simply didn't have the blockers to keep
away pressure for long enough to combo
so what did we decide to do with this
pool well I factored in placement in
games for purposes of deciding which
decks weren't working and my reasoning
for this is that a deck that doesn't win
much but is durable enough to stick
around a while is more fun than a deck
that doesn't win much and also gets
knocked out first each round the ratos
discard deck and to a lesser extent the
boros eggs deck was grindy and
interactive enough to stay alive whereas
the deir and iset decks had a tendency
to get knocked out first especially the
lazav deck so after three different
iterations of slower deir decks being
tried out the deir lazav deck was
replaced with a rogue based aggro Deck
with Sig River Cutthroat as the
commander it had become what it had
tried and failed to survive against with
this sig deck and a new is at
spellslinger deck the pool entered its
finished State we've only played about
25 games with the pool since these early
2021 updates and this is for the simple
reason that we each found things to do
with our lives aside from sitting inside
playing commander games don't get me
wrong I'm glad we did this final update
and the Sig deck I built for it is one
that I still occasionally pull out to
this day but most of these decks have
probably seen less than 10 games in the
past two years the fervor we had for
building tracking and updating these
decks was greatly fueled by the fact
that it basically all took place during
2020 and the first half of
2021 and the funny thing is the fact
that I had this major period of EDH deck
building during my college Years almost
certainly contributed to my decision to
begin making videos about the format so
in a sense salubrious snail is brought
to you by the covid-19 pandemic garbage
sponsor honestly would not recommend so
what is there to take away from this
little Fable I've weaved for you well to
start with I would say that if you're
tempted to make your own pool of decks
do it it's a super fun process and the
creation of a little metag game Within
These is neat in this video I probably
made this process seem highly analytical
but realistically we mostly just went
with what we felt like with the
constraint of two rules decks should be
a consistent power level and decks
should do something unique that other
decks need to consider both during games
and during the deck building process
there are a handful of somewhat more
generic decks in this pool such as simic
deir and iset but the other seven are
extremely evocative and put forth a
specific threat that requires
consideration the rose deck tries to
render the table hellbent by turn six
the grill deck inevitably explodes out
of control if it stays alive long enough
the aorus deck is a truly oppressive
control deck the grismold deck injects
an aggressive dose of Voltron into the
pool and the orav deck can dominate late
games through its mixture of board wipes
and life gain based combos I dug around
some old Discord messages while
scripting for this video and the
specificity of the decks within this
pool can be seen in how me Hans and
other players would talk about the decks
can this survive X can this pressure y
does this fold to Z if these decks were
all generic mid-range decks this thought
process would be wholly unnecessary but
since these decks are so Punchy and
evocative in what they do they demand
consideration so I guess what I'm saying
here is basically just that if you build
a set of decks like this don't let any
of them be overly weak or overly boring
and have the courage to be able to
dismantle a deck you like if it ends up
being one of these things as a final
point this process of building decks
formulated a lot of my understanding of
the commander format and when I started
building decks outside this pool in the
first half of 2023 I had kind of a rude
awakening where most of the games I
played were way less Dynamic and
interesting than the games with these
$25 decks my first Magic the Gathering
video was partially inspired by this
this experience of playing against Bland
formulaic decks without enough
interaction to make for a dynamic game
and while I've had plenty more
interesting games since then I try to
keep the mindset that I had when
building these $25 decks which is to say
try to present a specific problem for
your opponents and be prepared for if
your opponents present a problem for you
to me multiplayer games are more fun
when people have to think about their
opponents rather than when everybody is
just Racing Engines against each other
like we're all playing some kind of
second rate euro game
thanks for watching I linked a folder in
the description that contains the final
versions of all 10 of these decks though
some cards have gone up in price in the
past few years as cards have a tendency
to do I'm also releasing an end note
over on my patreon where I discuss the
orof deck in a bit more detail so if
that interests you you can head on over
there and throw some money at me